pierre de villenaux 18h34 vous êtes bien
en robe soir et on reprend les bonnes
habitudes après l'été on recommence nos
débats nos débats jusqu'à 19h avec
Isabelle foraine bonsoir porte-parole du
modèle et avec Jonas sa date bonsoir
bonsoir avocat et vice-président de la
Fondation concordent un petit mot sur la
Fondation Concorde parce que moi je
connais pas ah c'est un signe tant que
économique plutôt libéral et qui a
vocation à valoriser l'industrie et
l'énergie en France ça tombe bien ah bah
ça tombe bien vous voulez qu'on parle
d'énergie d'abord volontiers alors bah
tiens alors Agnès panière une hachée au
pupitre vêtue de rouge alors on sait que
c'est une certaine manière certains
savent que c'est sa couleur préférée
c'est aussi la couleur de l'énergie elle
est arrivée elle nous a dit qu'elle
avait 92% de stocks de gaz donc ça
devrait laisser passer l'hiver sauf si
on a un hiver extrêmement rigoureux et
puis alors il y a quand même cette
phrase sur les 32 réacteurs qu'on
devrait remettre en route alors que pour
l'instant ils sont en bienveillance
là-dessus Jean-Bernard Lévy avait fait
une sortie au MEDEF en disant mais
attendez on en a dû en faire mes 14 on
attend en attendant de surveiller les 32
qui sont en défection comment est-ce que
vous voyez ces annonces de Daniel
pennyrinager
la limite dure en même temps c'est à
dire que dans le quinquennat Macron 1 on
a voulu faire plaisir à la fois à ceux
qui étaient favorable au business mais à
ceux qui étaient aussi le pendant écolo
d'une certaine majorité et en fait
aujourd'hui on se retrouve à enfin
entendre les sonnettes d'alarme qui ont
été tirées mais même depuis bien
longtemps on parlait du patron d'EDF
mais il y a aussi le patron de
l'autorité qui s'occupait de la sûreté
nucléaire qui lui aussi depuis longtemps
à alerter et en fait volontariat du tout
dernier jour bien sûr on l'a pas écouté
et pardon mais il faut le dire aussi
pour que les auditeurs comprennent bien
mais je pense que l'argument a fait un
feu de paille ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'Ukraine si nous sommes dans cette
situation c'est par des choix
négatif et mauvais de la part du
gouvernement Hollande pour commencer
rendons à César ce qui est à César puis
Macron qui sont poursuivis qui ont
totalement déstructuré notre filière
nucléaire c'est pas Vladimir Poutine qui
a fermé Fessenheim c'est nous oui et
d'ailleurs madame born a été interrogé
là-dessus voilà récemment donc
malheureusement alors évidemment la
Russie et ce qui se passe vient
accélérer ce choc notamment et c'est là
aussi où il y a une erreur qui est
commise encore aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement notamment le choc gazier
puisque la reçu produit du gaz non pas
de l'électricité et les énergies
intermittentes comme les éoliennes qu'on
nous vend comme la panacée le
gouvernement nous vend ça comme la
panacée sont alimentés par quoi par du
gaz et donc en fait là on devrait au
moins corriger cette petite erreur là on
essaye encore de faire le même temps et
en fait le pantalon est en train de
craquer quoi voyez le grand écart c'est
bien mais à un moment là on doit si vous
voulez moi je pense que c'est le moment
et le gouvernement et il faut aussi être
clair elle avait commencé à amorcer un
virage positif se trouve juste avant la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron là en 2022 en
disant finalement c'est peut-être trompé
il faut peut-être repartir sur une
nucléaire mais voyez on a perdu du temps
et on a perdu une chance c'est à dire
que là on est déjà au taquet et dès
qu'il arrive une crise et ben on est à
la gorge Isabelle Floren sur le
nucléaire puisque c'est vrai que c'est
on en revient toujours là est-ce qu'il y
a pas eu quand même un pas en avant et
de pas en arrière
enfin en tout cas nous supporte parole
du MoDem et donc on a toujours été clair
sur le choix du nucléaire François Weil
ou la redit comme au commissaire au Plan
encore dans une autre stratégique sur la
filière on a toujours été donc très
clair au sein de la majorité sur la
fidèle nucléaire et le nécessaire
soutien justement parce que on voit bien
qu'en cas de crise en cas de choc
énergétique comme nous le vivons
actuellement c'est bien de parler de
sobriété il faut en parler et c'est
nécessaire mais on fera pas sans une
filière nucléaire sans le
en renfort donc très heureux entre
guillemets d'entendre la ministre de la
transition écologique énergétique tous
énergétique dire que il faut remettre
ces 32 réacteurs en service et de le
demander notamment à EDF mais oui
peut-être en tout cas sur l'énergie il y
a eu des hésitations sûrement sur le
précédent mandat il y a eu des
applications malheureuses mais des choix
qui avaient été fait par le mandat
précédent je vous ai laissé parler donc
juste me laisser terminer qui ont été
faits par le Parlement d'aprèscédant et
qui ont été effectivement des choix
dogmatiques et sur cette question là
faut sortir du dogmatisme les
écologistes moi je regrette
l'influence néfaste justement qu'ils ont
pu avoir un certain moment aussi dans
cette majorité je regrette on était en
opposition c'est même pas dû en même
temps c'est de reconnaître qu'à un
moment on peut pas faire sans une
énergie décarbonée mais on est très
clair il y a eu des débats il y a eu des
débats dans l'hémicycle il y a eu des
projets de loi il y a eu des débats sur
ces sujets on a toujours essayé nous de
d'être clair sur ces questions François
Bayrou a eu une position tout à fait
claire qui je pense à amener aussi à
cette assurance des manuels Macron et à
ses propositions en 2022 dans son
programme présidentiel mais voyez il y a
un moment là maintenant on fera sobriété
certes et on fera avec le nucléaire pour
passer j'espère aussi le cap de l'hiver
en espérant qu'il soit évidemment que la
météo soit pas très défavorable c'est ça
en gros ce qui est sorti du Conseil de
défense que disent les ministres et en
l'occurrence Agnès puisque on parle
d'elle sur
cette semaine effectivement elle a dit
que ça dépendra évidemment si on avait
un rigueur un hiver rigoureux ou pas et
c'est ce qui avait dit Madame borne
devant le Medel j'apprends à l'instant
que la centrale de vaporidja puisqu'on
parle beaucoup d'elle qui est vous le
savez en Ukraine et occupé par les
forces russes à deux nouveaux perdus la
connexion au réseau électrique cette à
nouveau voilà est-ce que c'est
inquiétant et puis vous êtes un expert
Jonas en énergie alors explore l'énergie
c'est un grand mot mais c'est vrai que
c'est inquiétant parce qu'en fait on
voit bien que on ne peut plus compter
sur cette région là voilà et juste pour
expliquer de nombreuses années pour des
nombreuses années et surtout et c'est le
cas de notre binôme qu'on voulait
constituer avec l'Allemagne 60% du gaz
allemand vient de la Russie et donc en
fait si vous voulez l'accélération du
choc gazier et du choc d'énergie qu'on
va avoir va être accélérée donc c'est
pour ça que je dis pas que tout est de
la faute du gouvernement mais en fait la
France avait vous voyez c'est un peu
comme dans d'autres secteurs on avait de
la souveraineté on n'avait pas besoin de
dépendre des autres et c'était
l'intuition magnifique du général de
Gaulle poursuivi par Pompidou on n'avait
pas besoin des là on s'est mis dans la
main
de une guerre on va attendre qu'il fasse
on espère que les températures sont pas
assez difficiles c'est des réflexions
pardonnez-moi mais de pays du
tiers-monde dans lequel on n'est pas en
capacité de pouvoir se dire vous voulez
dire on aurait pas dû soutenir l'Ukraine
et on aurait pas dû faire de sanctions
économique à la non pas du tout moi je
dis pas non mais vous êtes dit vous
venez de dire on s'est mis dans une
guerre on s'est mis dans rien du tout
d'abord on n'est pas cobelligérant non
et ensuite qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire exactement non quand je vous dis on
s'est mis dans les mains d'autres
personnes pour l'approvisionnement en
matière d'énergie mais c'est en fait en
remplaçant des situations si on avait
gardé toute notre dépendance nucléaire
si on avait gardé toute notre
indépendance vis-à-vis du gaz en mettant
moins d'énergie intermittente et bien on
aurait pas eu besoin juste du gaz des
Russes et et on aurait pu avoir les
mêmes sanctions d'ailleurs ce qui va se
passer parce que effectivement dans les
dans les mois qui viennent peut-être
qu'on reviendra au taux nucléaire
peut-être que il y a beaucoup de gens
qui qui changent d'avis maintenant sur
le nucléaire il y a eu un grand et puis
on en reparle on en parlait encore ce
matin avec les grandes voix de repas
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un traumatisme
avec aujourd'hui regardez les japonais
ils sont à nouveau revenus complètement
sur le nucléaire et puis tout va bien
c'est à dire que il y a une catastrophe
bon derrière il faut il faut aller de
l'avant il y a des prévisions également
qui ont changé et vous avez remarqué que
également dans le secteur de l'énergie
on voit bien que les prévisions sur la
consommation d'énergie ça c'est des
données de l'INSEE c'est des données
factuelles et des prévisions qui ont
changé en trois ans entre une baisse
finalement envisagée de la consommation
et une reprise de la consommation
globalement d'une d'une société on vit
aussi avec ces changements avec ces
chocs alors je suis d'accord
souveraineté énergétique on peut en
parler mais on peut en parler au niveau
européen ça c'est aussi un devoir et
c'est ça qui a été dit au Conseil de
défense c'est aussi cette réunion du 9
septembre cette solidarité européenne
nécessaire et ça oui mais le centre de
l'Europe enfin on dit souvent à tort à
mon sens que le centre j'allais dire
stratégique c'est le couple
franco-allemand est-ce que un jour Jonas
salade vous qui avec votre système
a observer également les autres pays
européens est-ce qu'un jour on peut
avoir un retour au nucléaire en
Allemagne ou est-ce que c'est
complètement fini c'est très compliqué
parce qu'une forme de consensus allemand
là-dessus l'Allemagne est aujourd'hui au
niveau des électeurs tout simplement et
même des des élus aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne son énergie il faut que les
auditeurs comprennent c'est un mix
éolienne et charbon ils en ont beaucoup
plus que nous des en ont beaucoup plus
que nous et Oli et charnons sauf que
ces technologies les deux émettent 10
fois plus de gaz à effet terre que
nucléaire et donc nous sommes dans un
rapport dans lequel ils ont pas les
déchets nucléaires certainement ah bah
oui par nature
et donc en fait dans une Isabelle
Florent la question franchement des
centrales à charbon et de la pollution
et effectivement de la consommation de
gaz éolienne et bien plus
problématique que la question de la
sûreté finalement et du fonctionnement
des centrales nucléaires le problème de
l'Allemagne c'est cette coalition il
finit depuis des années et en tout cas
cette présence finalement
mais en fait vous avez été dans la même
coalition c'est ce que j'ai c'est qu'en
gros vous avez vous comme eux en
Allemagne CD à l'aide écologiste
quand je vous entends dire tout à
l'heure il y a eu des débats au sein de
la majorité il y a pas eu de débat il y
a eu des décisions madame borne était
très fière en 2020 de venir à la radio à
la télé dire nous sommes les courageux
qui avons décidé de faire mes Fessenheim
et j'ajoute que en plus du fait qu'il y
a pas de débats mais qui a des décisions
c'est que une centrale à charbon a été
ouverte dans notre pays donc en fait
quand on dit on veut se baser au niveau
européen oui moi je suis pour le niveau
européen mais niveau européen à la
française pas l'Allemande parce que
sinon un on sera dépendant du gaz soit
de la Russie soit de l'Algérie et de on
peut lui rappeler donc il faudra
m'expliquer quel est l'intérêt de
s'aligner sur les Allemands
alors autre sujet parce que
effectivement vous mettra pas d'accord
sur sur l'énergie et on verra justement
c'est assez intéressant dans les
semaines qui viennent ce qui ce qui va
se passer surtout au niveau du retour en
Allemagne également
de la semaine prochaine à mon avis il va
être fondamental avec le chancelier
allemand justement et bien on va en
parler l'affaire
Gérald Darmanin mais d'abord peut-être
cette manifestation aujourd'hui sur la
République alors Chloé la gadoue nous
l'a compté n'arrêt tout à l'heure dans
le besoin du 18h avec 200 personnes sur
place autorisées à rien dire c'est à
dire que c'est le statu quo il y a juste
les organisateurs qui ont pris la parole
est-ce que ça vous a choqué d'ailleurs
Isabelle Floren la tenue de cette de
cette manifestation et comment est-ce
que vous avez vécu justement le
déroulement de cette manifestation qui
en fait n'a pas été une manifestation
comme d'habitude à corps et à créer avec
des des prises de parole c'est un flop
global enfin je veux dire 200 personnes
et heureusement à la limite parce que
une manifestation qui s'intitule
contre l'islamophobie en France enfin
moi je connais un petit peu le sujet
j'ai fait un rapport sur les actes
anti-religieux quand j'étais
parlementaire et ça n'existe pas il y a
des gens qui instrumentalisent
ce thème de l'islamophobie on les
connaît en France politiquement dans
l'échiquier ils sont quand même plutôt à
gauche à l'extrême gauche et ils s'en
servent régulièrement à chaque élection
pour remettre le sujet sur le tapis la
réalité c'est que malheureusement
la population est certain musulmans
peut-être peuvent être victimes d'acte
anti-musulman mais la réalité de l'imam
inacquisen c'est pas du tout ça la
réalité là c'est un prêcheur qui qui a
fait l'objet d'un arrêté qui devait être
expulsé un embroglio administratif que
je trouve enfin et que nous trouvons
tout à fait déplorable à commencer par
la décision du tribunal administratif et
on se retrouve avec un enchaînement
d'événements qui nous mettent devant la
réalité maintenant après la décision du
Conseil d'État que cette personne n'est
plus expulsable de France puisqu'elle
est plus sur le territoire français
vraisemblablement et qu'on imagine
qu'elle est en Suisse c'est enfin
franchement c'est c'est tout à fait
déplorable dans dans le sens où si vous
voulez on s'est battu en tout cas
derrière dans cette mandature aux côtés
de Gérald Darmanin nous avons voté une
loi contre le séparatisme pour justement
permettre d'accélérer et et que là on se
retrouve finalement avec une justice
administrative qui en premier ressort
ami à défaut la décision ministérielle
je l'ai tout de suite nous l'avons tout
de suite regretté qu'après des
politiques ne soient pas claires et ça
on les condamne et qu'ils aient joué aux
dernières élections présidentielles
comme législatives sur le
communautarisme et qu'il continue et que
finalement ils agissent une certaine
type de population autour de cette
prétendue islamophobie c'est un fait
qu'il faut combattre et qu'il faut
condamner condamner et continuer de
combattre c'est pour ça que je
continuerai à me battre sur ces sujets
ça montre que si on veut combattre
l'islamisme ce sera jamais contre les
musulmans mais avec les musulmans mais
parce que nos compatriotes musulmans
savent très bien et ils sentent qu'à un
moment il faut qu'on mette une barrière
très étanche entre ceux qui pratiquent
leur religion calmement tranquillement
et ceux qui utilisent la religion pour
tuer d'autres personnes deuxièmement ce
que ça démontre aussi c'est ça c'est
l'avocat qui vous le dit c'est que voter
une loi ça ne suffit pas malheureusement
madame ça suffit pas parce que c'est
bien de voter des lois c'est bien de
commenter des décisions de justice mais
c'est aussi bien de les exécuter et vous
savez le symbole de la justice c'est le
glaive donc évidemment il y a la balance
le moment dans lequel on désire et puis
après c'est le glaive le monde entier
c'est que une fois que le Conseil d'État
a pris cette décision moi ce que je
regrette c'est que cette personne-là qui
était fichée S n'est pas été surveillé
et que on n'est pas eu les moyens et la
capacité de faire en sorte qu'il évite
de fuir imaginez-vous 30 secondes
monsieur iqessen est censé être entre
guillemets l'ennemi public numéro 1 lui
il peut fuir vous imaginez les 3000
autres imam fraîcheur de haine si c'est
pas facile pour eux de pouvoir fuir ou
de pouvoir échapper à nos services de
surveillance c'est-à-dire que on a mis
dans l'état tous les moyens monsieur
Darmanin a dit vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir et même là on y arrive
pas ça montre aussi une forme de
défaillance d'une forme de si vous
voulez de de
mammouth un peu de bureaucratique sur la
capacité à pouvoir surveiller et à côté
de ça là on en revient en débat de on
peut pas mettre un flic derrière chaque
fichier s ça c'est
bien sûr derrière le fichier s de duquel
tout le monde parle depuis des semaines
à la télé dans les médias si on y arrive
pas là il y a peut-être une petite
problématique donc je pense moi que
c'est pas une victoire c'est plutôt une
défaillance de notre part que il
considère qu'il puisse se balader comme
ça et
il faut comme sur le sujet de l'énergie
pas dire en permanence à ses pas de
notre faute il est parti nous on avait
mis les choses en place il faut assumer
de dire que il y a une décision de
justice qui a été pris par des tribunaux
en l'occurrence le Conseil d'État et que
malheureusement l'exécution a failli
voilà ce que vous avez dit à propos des
musulmans jeunesse Adda désintéressant
vous dites il faut qu'on le fasse il
faut qu'on règle ce problème avec les
musulmans mais alors comment on fait
parce que il y a des instances
musulmanes il y a des conseils musulman
et un conseil du culte musulman comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour main dans la
montre
il y avait un forum maintenant
et bien ce qu'il faut moi je pense qu'il
y a chose d'abord il faut un convaincre
les cœurs si vous voulez c'est aussi à
nous et là on en vient aussi à la
thématique de l'éducation de faire en
sorte que dans toutes les classes de
France l'amour du pays soit non
négociable et c'est là aussi comme vous
j'en veux beaucoup à tous ces tenants
d'une extrême gauche qui en fait qui
passe leur temps à expliquer que la
France elle est raciste que la France et
l'islamophobe qui de Mélenchon mais de
ses alliés très clairement qui est
encore d'ailleurs dans une d'ailleurs
une exclusivité de Europe 1 à cette
semaine qui a très bien dit que une note
des renseignements territoriaux avait
dit que la plupart des leaders
islamistes avaient officiellement appelé
à voter pour Monsieur Mélenchon dans
n'importe quel autre pays du monde et je
le dis à ce micro ça aurait disqualifié
un leader politique de cet ordre là on
aurait dit celui-ci est un ennemi
potentiellement de la République parce
qu'il s'accoquine et il accepte le vote
de personnes qui sont dans cette
position moi je vous le dis très
clairement ça peut choquer des gens si
je dis que pour moi aujourd'hui les gens
qui sont autour de Mélenchon
sont des collabos parce que ils
collabore avec des gens qui ont tué
certains de nos compatriotes et donc il
se place dans cette position là et très
clairement il faut qu'on mette des
barrières étanchées quand je vous le
disais tout à l'heure que c'est avec nos
compatriotes musulmans qu'il faut qu'il
faut le faire c'est parce que je
dialogue beaucoup à certains de nos
compatteraient de musulmans qui me
disent on n'en peut plus d'être
instrumentalisé notre religion n'a rien
à voir avec la politique que c'est que
c'est genre d'extrême gauche nous laisse
tranquille et qui les arrête de nous
draguer pour quelques
vous dites ils nous disent on en peut
plus mais derrière d'accord mais
travaillons ensemble et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait moi je vous ai dit un éducation
mais deux une énorme fermeté sur le fait
que les prêcheurs de haine qui sont
étrangers soient tous renvoyés et vous
voyez la difficulté qu'on a eu à
attraper Gusen imaginait la difficulté
pour que tous les prêcheurs de hansoir
envoyés on les a pas tous renvoyés
deuxièmement et je le redis ici on ferme
toutes les mosquées dont on sait qu'il y
a des prêches ça n'a toujours pas été
fait et troisièmement et ça la loi vous
permettra c'est une réalité mais encore
une fois la loi elle permet mais vous
voyez c'est comme quand quelqu'un est
condamné et qu'on exécute pas sa peine
de prison la loi ne suffit pas qu'on
soit beaucoup plus ferme sur notre
relation avec les pays
dont les personnes sont ressortissantes
donc en gros c'est très clair
diplomatiquement notre combat c'est de
faire en sorte que toutes les personnes
qui sont de nationalité étrangère qui
prêchent la dans ce pays soit renvoyé
dans leur pays peu importe nos relations
avec les pays
à consulaire pour que
c'est passé consulaire ça c'est un autre
problème parce que il n'est pas toujours
là alors justement c'est ça que je
regrette le gouvernement le dernier
quinquennat a dit écoutez on va faire
une grande avancée on va réduire de 50 %
les laisser passer pour les personnes si
jamais on n'accepte pas de nous
récupérer des personnes qui sont des
délinquants ah ouais mais pourquoi 50%
pourquoi en même temps pourquoi un sur
deux pourquoi pas 100%
Isabelle Floren non mais on a
c'est facile enfin
de dire ce qu'il faut faire puisque on a
priori
c'était rien passé et or il s'est passé
des choses et je les ai à peu près
suivis pour dans 5 ans et pour vous dire
pas super bien vécu non plus parce que
notamment la relation avec l'Algérie et
la question de la restriction sur les
visas on l'a vécu je l'ai vécu en direct
sur le terrain très clair
donc la réalité elle est que oui il y a
eu des interventions oui le ministre de
la Justice oui le ministre de
l'Intérieur oui le président de la
République a fait appliquer cette
fermeté notamment sur les visas les
restrictions de visa oui c'est pas
facile sur le terrain quand après vous
avez des communautés vous avez des
ressortissants algériens qui viennent
vous voir toutes les semaines en disant
c'est insupportable et qui ensuite
finalement disent bon bah vous voyez on
est là depuis longtemps mais nous on
veut plus de nous et que tout ça rentre
dans la prolifération finalement de de
l'extrême gauche qui a réutilisé
finalement cette politique de formule C
que nous avons menée depuis un certain
nombre d'années vis-à-vis notamment de
l'Algérie et de ses ressortissants des
clandestins notamment des retours tout
ça c'est une politique qu'il faut mener
avec une vraie volonté politique je
crois que le gouvernement là
malheureusement
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué de
dialoguer avec l'Algérie j'espère que la
visite du président de la République et
on l'attendait depuis longtemps on
l'entende depuis longtemps cette visite
là donnera notamment aussi des résultats
en matière de retour en matière de
fermeté sur les entrées du territoire ou
sur les retours de clandestins ça c'est
une vraie politique ça doit être mené et
aller mener mais je vais vous dire c'est
bien on a on a des visions on a des gens
qui nous donnent des conseils très très
bien et et après il faut le vivre et
après il faut le faire je suis d'une
circonscription vous savez monsieur ou
il y a un consul il y a une communauté
algérienne et pour l'avoir vécu sur le
terrain tous les jours ce n'est pas si
simple à faire appliquer merci beaucoup
à vous deux merci beaucoup Jonas et
merci